été commenté noël autrefois autrefois
pas de grands repas de fête ni de
cadeaux sous le sapin
ni même de télévision nombreux étaient
les français qui allaient à la messe de
minuit
alors pour s'occuper en attendant ce
moment fort de l'année les membres de la
famille se racontaient des histoires une
tradition aujourd'hui oubliée il y avait
des vieux comme une tradition qui crée
du lien social entre générations tout en
permettant à certains grands parents
d'en rajouter un peu comme un conte de
noël sa politique a tout de même en
aragon guibal pas celui là
ces histoires faisait le bonheur des
enfants excités à l'idée de pouvoir
veiller aussi longtemps durant cette
soirée magique
la vraie fête c'était compte d'abord
pour les enfants nous étions nous avions
le droit de veiller
rendez vous compte on veillée autour la
cuisinière jusqu'à minuit et après passé
minuit
c'était la seule fois de l'année selon
les régions la veillée de noël se
dérouler soit en famille soit au sein
d'un groupe social plus élargie ainsi au
pays basque en 1968
ces bergers passer noël en entonnant des
chants traditionnels de noël en ce monde
répandent partout la même allégresse
comme le fils il ya 2000 ans la
naissance de l'enfant jésus
[Musique]
mais progressivement la messe de mini
perd de son importance alors plus besoin
de payer aussi longtemps
certains restent cependant nostalgiques
de ce noël d'autrefois un filon pour ces
acteurs de théâtre qui en 1999 recréer
l'ambiance des anciennes veiller les
contes de noël à domicile
c'est la dernière invention de la troupe
des chercheurs d'art associe une veillée
qui démarre sur les chapeaux de roue
comme les ombres donné que du loup se
met à danser sur la neige aujourd'hui de
moins en moins de français vont à la
messe de noël
le repas est devenu le moment fort du
réveillon de noël
le temps du partage des légendes pendant
la longue veillée est bel et bien
révolue
[Musique]